i like it when i can make an investment
in a company
and in three or four years i get all my
money if you're going to take all your
money and put it into the market today
into the index that's probably
not the best idea i think the single
greatest skill
an investor needs to do well
is extreme patience
hello believe nation in today's video i
get to sit down with one of the world's
greatest investors
and pick his brain about investing
building wealth and what made him so
successful as an investor and what he's
looking for
in today's investments now he's not only
changed my life through his values
teachings and principles
but he's impacted countless of lives
within the investment community
he started the pr investment funds in
the early 2000s right after the dot-com
bubble
and since then has had a rate of return
of 671
plus for his investors he's not only
amazing investor
but he's also a philanthropist starting
the dakshima
foundation in india helping pull kids
out of poverty
and putting them through the i.t program
to change their lives and their families
lives
he's also written an amazing book that's
highly regarded within the investment
community called
the dondo investor that i would highly
recommend you check out if you're
looking
to dive more into investing so with that
said
i hope you sit back relax and enjoy the
interview the first question i want to
ask you
would be with the s p 500 um
being at a p e of 40 um
and things kind of just out there in uh
you know all-time highs uh do you see
any resemblance between the dot-com
bubble and what's going on in
any caution that you um feel right now
in the markets yeah well i think the the
dot-com bubble was uh
more widespread um it was a little
you know each of these bubbles have
their own nuances and characteristics
uh during the dot-com bubble what
happened is that
a bunch of businesses that really had
no revenues and not really much more
than a website
had gotten some crazy valuations and so
on
and it was pretty widespread in the
sense that uh
people could create any kind of dot com
and you know
it would get venture funding and and uh
kind of go from there
and some of that had spilled into the
mainstream s p stocks like things like
coca-cola was pretty highly priced
microsoft
cisco systems and so on and later all
these stocks crashed and burned so there
was
a bubble in the dot coms there was also
a bubble in
tech and there was a bubble in what i
would call maybe
you know well recognized blue chips
if you look at the situation today
i think it's much narrower
in the sense that the real bubble is in
the robinhood names
or the wall street bet names uh
so um maybe you can add bitcoin to that
uh to that mix as well uh so it's
it's much uh much narrower
uh than than what we had before uh
we do have uh some similarities in the
sense that
we have stretched valuations in uh
in a number of uh sexy tech businesses
uh you know salesforce microsoft
uh alphabet airbnb all of those uh kinds
of businesses
uh so there's there's some euphoria
there but it is
nothing like what's happening with the
robin hood names and so on
and then when you get past this core
then i think it is questionable whether
we
have stretched valuations because we
have very low interest rates and if
those
low interest rates persist uh
you know uh that that actually impacts
uh long-term stock valuations so
so i think the uh there is definitely a
bubble
uh but the bubble is much narrower and
in terms of the
the popularity with the
escaping the mutual funds and the high
costs
and going over to the indexes do you see
a bubble within the indexes forming or
do you still
think there is you know more room for
that to grow
down the road well i mean i think the uh
the s p is clearly at elevated
valuations
um if if an investor is
young and going to dollar cost average
over a long period of time
uh the s p p 500 500 is just fine
if you're going to take all your money
and put it into the market today into
the index
um that's probably not the best idea
so if if you're a young young investor
you've got decades
of compounding ahead of you then i don't
think it matters
okay in terms of in terms of with the
low
interest rates um and there's still
being room for growth do you see
uh an adjustment in the p e ratios that
we should be expecting from companies
i know in one of your earlier talks you
um and i know you've recently switched
to
going after spawners as opposed to the
discounted pies
uh and i was curious to know in terms of
you know thou
shall not invest in a company over a pe
of 10 um should we be setting new
barometers uh within you know acceptable
peas that we'll just have to
gulp down essentially well i would say
that
if you if you step uh if you
if you move from indexing to
picking individual stocks uh
that is a significant step change um
so so if you're if you're going to pick
individual stocks
then you've got to have a very good idea
of what kind of cash flows those
individual
businesses are likely to produce over
the next 5 or 10
or 15 years and if you have a good
handle on that
then you can work backwards and discount
those cash flows and come up with the
intrinsic value for a business uh most
humans
would not be good at doing that and
most companies do not lend themselves to
that type of
uh forecasting that's relatively easy to
do
so so i would i would be reluctant
to uh to suggest
that individual investors look at
individual stocks because
uh a price to earnings ratio is one data
point
uh it's not the be-all and all of
investing it's it's a single data point
it has relevance but it also may not
have relevance
in the case of many businesses
and so in terms of um distinguishing
that
that the two people who um are
interested the vast majority who maybe
should take the indexes and dollar cost
average
if they're not willing to take on the
approach of diving into specific
companies
um the the next step up for those
individuals and then i do really want to
come back to the specific individuals
who are curious
to dive into specific companies as well
but
i guess going back to the general
mass in terms of investing in an index
versus something like berkshire hathaway
which is an index of itself of course
and maybe taking that pursuit versus the
index
do you see the berkshire
hathaway having a long run even after
charlie and warren
uh part ways with it essentially i hope
they're still around for
20 years plus but um yeah one could
one could think of berkshire
kind of sort of like an index although
that's a little bit of a stretch
and i think that in today's environment
it would not be a bad idea if you were
dollar cost having
over a long long time to do 50
s p and 50 workshop uh
that's not a bad way to go and uh i
think both are
valid it's it's difficult for me to
uh be clear which one would do better
over the next five or ten years that's
not clear to me
do you still think berkshire does uh it
comes down to i guess the
the management of berkshire and how much
charlie and warren
have built berkshire do you still see
uh the potential uh
value within berkshire even after those
individuals yeah i don't think it will
matter
i mean clearly warren and charlie are
exceptional
but they have a deep bench and they have
some really good managers
and uh they have done a lot of planning
for succession
uh so i think that the the bigger
challenge for berkshire
is not so much the transition for warren
and charlie
it's uh the problem of size
and uh they already faced that problem
today with warren and charlie
in the mix so uh so size is a
major factor which will
uh serve as an anchor
to their performance but uh they've
pulled rabbits out of hats and they will
do that okay and in terms of the
the specific investor who is willing to
dive into the companies
and going back to thou shall not
invest in pe of 10 you know looking at a
company
uh because the audience is is very mixed
between people who
should take the index investing approach
dollar cost in berkshire
um but we do have a lot of warren
buffett disciples
and individuals um and so i guess in
terms of the
when looking at companies uh looking at
for example spawners
uh like costco for example that you
talked about um i believe was two talks
ago
um and seeing that maybe there is a case
to be made
where they're not they do have room to
grow
yeah i think costco is a very good
example i think costco is a
incredible business and uh i think it's
a business that will be
much larger in the future um for example
they just opened one store
in china uh which was mobbed uh
and they they couldn't even let the
people in because there was so much
demand shelves got cleaned out
it is entirely possible that in 10 or 20
years
there are hundreds of stores of of
costco in china
and it's also possible that at some
point the chinese business of course
could
be bigger than the american business of
costco
um and costco is in very few countries
they're just in a handful of countries
so
costco could enter more countries
so i think there's many ways for costco
to grow
quite significantly from where they are
at today
but that does not mean that it would be
a great long-term investment
so a business doing well in the future
um is usually a requirement for you to
do well as an investor
uh but just because the business does as
well
uh does not mean you will do well so
costco
is not cheap by
traditional metrics today um
the future of costco is well understood
by the markets and many investors who
have were willing to pay up for it
it would not be clear to me whether it's
better to invest in costco
or better to invest in berkshire better
to invest in s p 500
between those three i couldn't tell you
which one to do well i
i would say this that uh while i admire
costco tremendously at current prices i
would not be a buyer of the stock
in terms of making that distinguishing
factor of not just with costco
costco just being the example of um
you know charlie for example saying you
know it's better to pay for
a wonderful business at a fair price
than um
you know a decent business at a at an
attractive price
with with example like costco where
it's it's not cheap like you just said
with the current
business how would you assess the risk
for individuals who did want to take on
that pursuit of not just costco but any
business
where you're investing in
the potential something or multiple
factors going right
versus investing in the underlying
business of what's already gone right
okay so you know that's uh just to
highlight why
the individual stocks is a
it's fraught with peril let's just uh
dive a little deeper into costco
uh just so i can express what i'm trying
to get to
so the market cap of costco today
is a little over 145 billion
okay and what yahoo finance is showing
me
is that the trailing p e ratio is 33.
33.72 let's just
make the math simple let's say the
market gap is
um
you know let's say it's 150 billion and
let's say the pe is 30 for example
okay so uh what that means is that
uh costco earned
5 billion dollars in the last 12 months
and it will have some earnings stream
coming out
in the next 10 or 20 years
okay and let's say for example
costco's earnings i mean let's just take
a
and i haven't done this math before i'm
going to do it on the fly with you
but let's take a very bullish case on
costco and let's say that
costco is able to double its earnings
every five years you know so uh 15
rate of earnings growth would be uh
quite high
so what that would mean is that they
would be making around 10 billion
in five years and they'd be making
around 20 billion
in 10 years and so if you look at the
the next 10 years of cash flows
which start at 5 billion and
end at 20 billion uh
all those cash flows uh together
um i mean uh we have to do the math on
that but
basically i'm just guesstimating it
maybe around
maybe 100 billion or so or less in total
then you would discount those back
you know with some interest rate or
something you take those back you might
discount it by five percent or something
i don't know
so the thing is that it's a business
that you
put out 150 today
and you get back uh
less than 150 dollars in the next 10
years
after some very robust growth
and assuming no hiccups
that does not strike me as the most
exciting place
to invest now if we did the same math
with gamestop or
tesla or
you know sales force for example
the math would look even more ridiculous
i mean costco is not in a bubble it's
not very overpriced
it's it's a very great business uh
but still you can see that and so um
i like it when i can make an investment
in a company
and in three or four years i can get all
my money back
right i mean if i can if if i could
invest 150
in costco and in the next four years the
earnings were more than that
oh that'd be a great investment but that
is not in the cards
for for the individuals out there who
are looking to buy these wonderful
businesses at a at a discount but there
just seems to be
nothing out there for individuals in the
united states unless
maybe you're looking globally um but for
for people who really do want to stay in
their
circle of competence and don't want to
expand out of it do you see a case to be
made
for people to who are willing to take on
the knowledge of investing
sit in cash or do you think they should
be
potentially not missing the opportunity
in the s p 500 or uh
berkshire for example these are
difficult questions i think the single
greatest skill
an investor needs uh to do well
is extreme patience and
and so if one wants to buy individual
stocks
and one is not able to find something
that's actually that's a pretty normal
situation uh
it's probably safer to just let the cash
sit
not put into the index because the index
could go down so then when
the opportunities come up to buy stocks
at great prices
your index could be down 20 and so then
you've
now lost 20 of your firepower
so i think that if you were going to be
a stock picker
uh willing to sit with
sums in your checking account not
earning anything for long periods
is just par for the course and the
market
eventually that you typically throughout
history we do see
a correction or something where maybe
there's an opportunity down there i mean
i think we're not
we're i think if you're going to pick
individual stocks and graphic individual
stocks i really don't care about the
market
uh and actually the thing is because
there are 50 000 stocks around the world
individual companies always going
through issues at different times so it
doesn't even matter better what's
happening
with the markets there may be some event
happening at some individual business
which
collapses the price for not very good
reasons
and that's the opportunity you're
looking for
you're looking for extreme mispricing
and in an auction-driven market there's
extremist pricing
happening all the time in terms of
investing
globally um i know i know i've heard you
talk about um being invited out from
people
to go look at their
their companies and individuals
helping you walk through the process for
the individual stockbroker
who does want to take this journey and
not just dollar costs through the index
like warren buffett recommends and
um uh you know just escape the low fees
um is there is there uh a way that you
recommend individuals who maybe don't
have access to people who
would be willing to help yeah i think i
think the starting point should be
businesses whose products and services
you use
if if you are a customer of apple
um you have some familiarity with the
company to start with
so that's that's a good starting point
so if you just look at all the different
products and services that
you as an individual are consuming it
could be amazon it could be
spotify number of different things
uh i would say those are the first
businesses
you should try to look at and try to get
your arms around because clearly they
were able to convince you
to become a customer so they've they've
been able to
convince you to part with your precious
dollars and
uh and and
you know we become a customer so so i
would say that
that you know sticking to circle of
competence is important
the starting point could be just looking
at i mean i've repeatedly found
in looking back that there are many many
companies
that i was a die-hard fan of
and a die-hard customer of and
i failed to analyze the business
properly
and they were huge home runs and
a lot of stuff could have been figured
out if i had been willing
to dive in so i've lost a lot of uh
there's a lot of opportunity cost when i
have not
uh looked at these businesses
more carefully because generally
speaking um
we are all very careful about who we
interact with and which companies we do
business with
and so if they've passed that first
layer of having trust with you
uh that means the business is doing
something right
and it probably means that they may have
some legs
in the future so i think that's the
starting point
in terms of over the years um
in terms of your circle of confidence
has that naturally just grown through
digging in
the companies and being exposed to the
other ones or if you
actively took it upon yourself through
methods
or certain things to help expand your
circle of competence yeah i mean i think
that one should not
fixate on increasing or broadening the
circle of competence
i think if you're curious about business
uh
it is a natural outcome i think if
you're curious about different companies
and you read up on them and drill down
and figure them out
that circle will gradually expand but
you don't need to really sweat it it'll
just
it's going to be happening to osmosis
in terms of um i guess taking another
route so i know um circle of confidence
uh
warren buffett talks a lot about um
you know knowing what what you don't
know
which would be the circle of confidence
and the other aspect being of course the
margin of safety
and the other aspect being management
which i'm curious to ask you about
so let's say you do have a business in
your circle of confidence and
you were able to find it at attractive
price
and maybe perhaps the story changes with
management
a ceo stepping down or
how do you how would you assess that
risk
even getting it at a good price
what framework would you go through
in order would you cut the the portfolio
down a bit
based on that story i think every
situation is going to be different
there are some businesses where
management is very critical and
there are other businesses where
uh management to the large extent i mean
if you owned stock in the coca-cola
company
and the ceo dropped red tomorrow
uh that shouldn't be a reason to sell
the stock
uh you know a lot of ceos have come and
gone from coke
uh it's really the brand and the moat
that
is relevant there and they probably have
plenty of people who could lead the
business
and and such so so i think it depends on
on the business um management is
critical for most companies
uh so it just depends i think you you
can't make a blanket statement about
that is
each situation be different mm-hmm in
terms of a company like um
certain growth properties where you see
a cfo
and a ceo leave
you know do you having to re-dig maybe
back through the process
of investing um and just looking at that
company again
do you go through the the underlining
business again
when something like that happens and
just make sure
uh everything is okay or
i will duck the question on heritage
uh because i really don't want to talk
about businesses that are
currently in the portfolio but i think
what is publicly known
is that uh our stake did not
change after the cfo and the ceo left so
both of them left in in
2020 and we
we uh i think we posted our position
holdings as of the end of the year
and if you look at our holdings on our
13f filings
on december 31st and
uh september 30th
there's nothing meaningfully different
so i can just give you that fact but i
can't go into
right any more color on that at some
point in the future we will not
own saritage i don't know when that is
but if we talk
after that then we will
tear it apart perfect i look forward to
that
in terms of going back to you talking
about um coke for example
and just finding a wonderful business
where even if the ceo drops dead
maybe it is not necessarily a case to
sell because it's such a wonderful
business
looking for these spawners the new
discovery that you you talked about
in the in the lecture you recently gave
um how have how have coming to this
discovery with the spawners
um made you update any big changes
within the checklist
you look for when investing in companies
well the
i think the checklist is more to avoid
uh permanent losses of capital
so the checklist is a more kind of
defensive
tool to help you avoid pitfalls
um it's not designed to
identify you know great home runs
but generally speaking if a company has
spawn or dna
uh it's a business worth paying
attention to
because because it's got multiple ways
to marijuana
and and so so i think that
um uh you know like i mean i would just
say that if you look at a company
um i mean uh
just to give you an example softbank in
japan it's not a spawner
but uh but but softbank
uh has had many many investments
that have turned out to be useless
they made many many errors in investing
but their record
looks exceptionally good because
they had a few investments where they
were
completely right and they were
smart enough to hold it all the way
through so for example
i think i think uh masa invested
like 25 or 27 million dollars into
alibaba
and they still own i think
a 20 20 stake in alibaba and
it's a massive home run it's a large
portion of the total value
of softbank is the stake in alibaba same
with
yahoo japan they made an investment in
yao japan very little was invested
it's worth a lot he was alibaba is
clearly a spawner
it's a great spawner and masa for
whatever reason
decided to buy and hold alibaba
and that one decision overrides
dozens of stupid ones and
and so that's the nature of investing is
that you don't need to always get it
right but i think if you generally
invest in spawners
uh below or
at reasonable valuations um
and you hang on for the ride uh some
very good things can happen to you
in terms of finding um when you were
looking at all these spawners
um were there any common themes that you
found earlier on
to catch them sooner was it was there
return on invested capital higher
was there any any common attributes that
you found
when looking back at all these spawners
that we've had recently
that you are now applying to
look for the the new ones to come that
could be a 10 to 100 bagger
yeah so uh when i when i
kind of got somewhat enlightened about
spawners the first thing i did i looked
in my portfolio
and i noticed that there were some
businesses i already owned a
portion of which had spawner dna
um so i felt like forrest gump at that
point
you know i invested in a food company
out west um and um
so that was great but what what it did
help me with
what it uh what it did was the framework
of me looking at that business changed
or those businesses changed i said okay
now
now that we understand how spawning
works
um we need to let this ride for a while
let it ride don't don't sweat it that oh
the pe is 20 now and
uh something else will available to peo
8 or something
uh let it ride so that was the first
thing and the second is that when i'm
looking at new businesses
or businesses that i'm studying
businesses all the time uh it's easy for
me to tell
what is and isn't a spawner and
so i can start segmenting them and if if
i run into spawners
and they look reasonably priced and so
on and spawning is a very
wide area you know there's a there's a
continuum of spawning there's some
companies which could have
some spawning ability but they're not
kind of major spawners
on the other hand there's something like
amazon
which is an apex spawner which is just
extremely good at it and they
focus on it so as you get closer to the
spectrum
towards the alibaba and the amazons of
the world
those are the businesses that you have
to be willing to pay up for
and you have to be willing to hold for a
long time
and for the um i believe it was
charlie who said uh i'm paraphrasing
here you know even if it's a mistake it
corrects itself
long term um yeah i mean i think i think
a good
time is the friend of a good business
and i mean like like if you
bought costco at current prices and the
market crashed 30
tomorrow costco may drop more than 30
but if you just kept it for five or ten
years
the odds that you would lose money are
close to zero
yeah very fascinated with your with the
spawner discovery
um and and you you sharing this
information with me
um and everyone um i guess in terms of
when looking for these spawners so of
course you know alibaba or
um amazon you know not go it
you know how how much bigger could they
grow um
so you know you won't be finding a 10 to
100 bagger there maybe
jeff jeff still says it's day one
right day one don't tell
jeff amazon's not gonna grow right right
that's not what he believes
yeah i mean i think i think amazon is is
not an easy business
to invest in today it may still continue
to do extremely well
for investors for a long time the same
with alibaba
but clearly i mean the thing is that
the smaller and earlier that you're able
to find the business which has spawning
dna
the issue is that you have greater
runway
if that happens but you also have
greater uncertainty
because they haven't gone through the
journey they may or may not
get there without stumbling
right so that's the that's that's what
makes it uh somewhat challenging but if
you had a number of bets maybe
five or ten bets like that uh you really
need just
one or two to work and then you ride off
into the sunset like masa
right right um i guess in terms of for
the individual stock picker
when viewing that and looking at
companies maybe you know
small cap mid stock mid cap companies
who aren't the blue chips maybe
companies that are
you know not in the news as much harder
to follow
um i know i know over
leveraging is a is a huge aspect that
you're not a fan of
with companies are there any other areas
of indication
should people be wary of for the
individual stock picker when when
looking for companies that
have this greater runway besides
overload of debt
yeah i know i think that there are many
many businesses because they're like i
said their 50 000 stocks
globally there's many many businesses
that
still have massive runways ahead of them
and have had 10 or 20 years of history
that you can look at
so if if a business has you know 20
years of history
um and you know that he should be able
to tell you something about the
ability of that business to navigate and
survive and grow in the next
decade or two those things would
mitigate risk factors and
so it's not true that
every business with a lot of history is
already as big as amazon alibaba and the
story's over
that's not true there are many many
businesses where
at the age of 20 they're just getting
started
i guess um looking for a track record of
yeah sometimes it could be a manager who
moves into a business and the manager
has a long record uh so it just depends
you know
it's i think these are these are what
these are the things that make my life
interesting
when i look at different businesses
because each one
is different each one has
nuances going on with it and the
the challenge i have is to first make
sure that i'm
operating within my circle of competence
and then
uh you know find the ones with the
great spawner dna and the grade one
runway ahead
uh without paying too much for that
taking it in another direction
speaking of your life um i'm very
curious to know what what the day in the
life of uh
monash looks like well i mean i think
the
a day in my life is uh it just depends
actually what's going on on
uh what day i mean uh i have very few
things on my calendar
uh i try to avoid putting things on my
calendar i learned that from buffett
buffett runs almost a
empty calendar so the first thing i try
to do is
i really try to control
um you know what what goes on the
calendar and
so i'm an introvert by nature that works
well for me
uh i'm happy when i'm with myself and my
books and my reading
that's good and uh so my
my the way i plan my week is
really to keep it completely open that's
the way i try to and
keep it open so that serendipity is
possible
so i can i can read different things
that i may have an interest in
uh i can look at different things you
know
recently i got two books
and i haven't read either one
too much yet but they're both books on
general electric
okay so one is a book called lights out
which is a i think it's a
critical look at jeff immelt
and ge and how poorly the business has
done
in the last 20 years while jeff was
running it
uh and the second is a book by
um that by jeff immelt that just came
out
which is called hot seat and in that
book
you know there are very few things that
went wrong
edgy from jeff's point of view when you
read the other book which is lights out
uh it's a basket case
right and so to me it's interesting to
read both the books
uh to see the different points of view i
mean
i'm never going to invest in ge okay
that's not
in the cards i'm not interested but i am
curious
about how this
this company that was trading at 50
times earnings
uh in the jack welch era before
jeff i melt came in and how it
you know has lost its way and now it's
trying to get its way back
uh it's just interesting you know it's
the nature of business right
and um so i think that
in terms of my uh
my schedule and and such
i like to keep things open so that if i
do find something
you know some juicy meat with some good
meat on the bone
then i can uh dive in you know and uh
see if it is truly a wonderful piece of
meat or not
right and i guess going back to your
your reading um reading taking up you
know
the interesting thing about every
successful investor uh
is they love to read and and so i'm
curious to know um
how how much how much do you read per
week um
is that is that where most of your time
is taking up
uh yeah i mean i mean the job
description is reading and thinking so
i think the reading is is diverse i
i still read newspapers in
physical form uh so
i have three newspapers
i read every day so the wall street
journal
new york times and financial times
all the physical copies of all three
the weekends i get barrens as well which
is a
good good read so that's the the
newspaper reading is happening all the
time
uh then in addition to that there are
you know maybe i think maybe 100 books a
year
or something that i'm i'm reading and
then uh beyond that there's annual
reports
and then drill downs on companies and
things
along those lines in terms of everything
you've read
um i guess every book you've read are
there are there three books
um you would say are a must read for
people who do want to pursue
investing as a as a career
yeah i mean i think that uh i think
i would put poor charlie's almanac up
there as
one of the best books to read i think
that one book if you read it carefully
is better than a college degree
and much cheaper and i try to reread
that every year
and every year when i reread it i find
stuff that i could swear i never read
before
i think then some of the buffett
biographies like
the one i like is lowenstein's making of
american capitalists
is a very good read
and and i think a third book if i can
plug that is a book that's coming out
in about six weeks
um and it's a it's by a guy named
william green and uh it's called uh
richer wiser happier
and he
profiles a bunch of great investors in
there
and i'm the opening batsman
so maybe that's why i'm biased but
william is a very gifted writer
and i think uh people will get a lot out
of his book i learned a lot from his
book
and that comes out six weeks from now
yeah and now you can go on amazon and
pre-order
just to make sure they don't run out
right
and and the the dondo investor as well
your own book investor of course sure
is perfectly fine no but i think
william's book is
really spectacular it helped me
redo my frameworks uh
when i when he finally sent me the
the manuscript and such to look at and
so i think he's done an
exceptional job he's a very gifted
writer
and i think it's uh the book will do
really well
excited to check that out yeah well i
guess before i move on to
um another question would you ever write
a book on spawners down the road as this
thesis plays out in this new discovery i
think that at this point there are no
plans and also the
i think the spawner framework is very
new
uh i had some
thoughts on it which i shared uh
with the uh students and then on youtube
uh i think um maybe in the next few
years i might get
more maturity around the
uh the framework uh but i'm
i'm not uh focused on writing any more
books
it's too much work right
yes but thank you for doing so
um yeah the dondo investor like i told
you um at the beginning just
yeah really launched me into
entrepreneurship and investing
uh one of the first three books i've
ever read but yeah and i think my
motivation for writing that book
was to crystallize certain frameworks in
my own mind
so i really wrote that book for myself
and just to get
certain things crystallized so even if i
were to do something
with the spawners it would really be i
would do it from the point of view
and one of the reasons i shared that
that framework
is because i actually was hoping i would
get
feedback from people who
saw the video or people in the class
which would help me with the framework
and that is
that has been happening i've gotten a
bunch of different emails from different
people and such and
uh so that's that's wonderful
well if you do i'll i'll be your first
reader
creating that second book um but i've
also been curious about
um you know as you as you continue to
um read and dive into these companies
um companies you love that maybe are not
attractive prices that you could buy
them at
and you build this wish list um
as you build this wish list how do you
manage that wist list wish list when
it's in a time of
you know high valuations and it just
seems to keep growing how do you stay on
track of that wish list and not get it
overflowing necessarily yeah i mean i
think
uh the wish list is fine but i think a
better
approach is to keep hunting
so because we have so many stocks around
the world
uh there are events taking place
that are affecting individual businesses
okay like for example when
the chinese government gets bent out of
shape
on what jack ma said
alibaba stock fell it
didn't matter what was happening to the
index of the markets it fell
right and and
if you had a viewpoint on whether the
issues are temporary or permanent and
such
it may be something that's actionable so
like that there is constantly because
all these businesses are living
breathing
entities they're going through ups and
downs they are releasing different data
to the market sometimes the markets
don't like
what they hear and and so you have all
of that
playing out uh there will be
they will for sure be uh
businesses and countries and entities
that get widely mispriced in the middle
of all that
so i think if if you you can keep a list
of businesses you love
in reading to go on sale that's fine by
which i keep the hunt on
looking for new ones and just keep
sifting through that
i enjoy that hunt right and it's a lot
of fun yeah
and in terms of that um going on the
hunt and
going for you know the 50s looking
through the 50 000
stocks um out there um
and you know for the individual stock
picker who
um you know is from the united states
canada um
where you just you you know that's in
your circle of competence
you still have 5000 stocks right
no problem there's still plenty
right yeah in terms of i guess in terms
of building the confidence of an
investor when when you do
find something that's undervalued how do
you distinguish the two between knowing
that you founded versus you know
maybe wall street or no one else finding
it
um how do you have that confidence um
when when making that decision is it
just the amount of work
you put in or is it the experience
you've had over the years
yeah i mean i think in in in different
situations
it's different if you get to a point
of an epiphany
and that epiphany you have a very strong
amount of conviction about that epiphany
um you can act on that
okay so for example uh you know
in uh in 2012
i had made an investment in fiat
chrysler
automobiles right and uh i hated the
auto business i always hated them
it's a terrible business and
and but when i was studying fiat i spent
about three months studying it was
really
fascinating for me uh i encountered that
they had brought in a
spectacular manager and
this manager uh sergio marchionne who's
passed away now
was totally off the start off the charts
i mean there were harvard case studies
on him
there was a lot of trademarks in the
past that you could look at about what
he had done
and the second is that when
gm and fiat went through bankruptcy
uh they really cleaned out
a lot of the cobwebs and ugliness of the
business so for example the uaw
contracts
got redone and they got redone in the
manner that made
detroit a great place to build cars and
so
there was a number of things happening
at the same time
and i could see that the market just
hated those businesses they just because
they'd come out of bankruptcy and they
were not
focusing on the fact that there was a
great manager who had come in
and that fiat was a company that had 135
billion in sales
and the whole market cap was 5 billion
and ferrari was inside fiat
inside that 5 billion for our ferrari
alone is worth
30 plus billion now um so
it was a very significant home run
because you had two or three things
going on
uh at the same time which were all going
to compound on each other so
detroit went from being on the worst
places to build a car to be
one of the best it became very
competitive uh you had a great manager
and
fiat chrysler had a very strong
footprint
on suvs and trucks and
suvs and trucks were becoming they've in
fact now become more than
half the market they've taken over
sedans right so they
they were just perfectly positioned so
there were these multiple
layers of things that are all going to
move
all those factors are going to move in
the same direction
and so if you get conviction like that
you know people didn't want to invest in
some italian company and they didn't
want to invest
in some auto company and all all of
these things
and it was and it had a lot of debt it
was mispriced
and
that's it you have in investing you have
plenty of time to do the work
uh there's no hurry uh and you can
uh you can spend the time do the work
and then
uh you know if seven moons line up you
can uh make an investment
and if things uh you don't feel
great about them i feel goosey about
something take a pass move on to the
next one
right and and when you did feel the the
the um diving into fiat for example
um did you uh i guess how long
did that did this um
logic reasoning add up through the
research
to to come up with a decision of fiat
would be a great opportunity
yeah i mean i spent several months
studying it and
but i started buying this talk after a
few weeks
but i was just so fascinated with the
business and there was so much to
study there were so many books written
on the auto business
and i read the uaw contracts and
there was a lot of history on sergio i
could look at
uh so there was just there was a ton of
data available
and uh and it all pointed to me like
this
would be a difficult business to lose
money on
this investment would be very unlikely
to not work out
right i mean basically uh fiat got
gifted chrysler they paid almost nothing
for it
because the u.s government was almost
ready to liquidate christ
so they picked up a very significant
asset
for next to nothing and that asset
is incredibly valuable i mean
the just a truck business in the u.s for
example
has 25 import tariffs
so you could not make a truck in china
and bring it to the u.s
and be competitive because you'd pay a
25 tariff on that
the labor component in a truck is less
than
three or four percent of the price so if
chinese labor is zero
you would make the truck truck maybe for
five percent less
okay and then you'd have a 25
tariff to bring it in so
it's you couldn't and and the loyalty
levels of the truck buyers
they're very loyal to the three brands
so this is why toyota which has been in
the truck business in the us forever
even manufacturing in texas has not
gotten traction i mean the powerful
you know with that that is toyota uh
even they couldn't crack it interesting
so you just you know you just pee in the
neighbors
and then you could see the same thing
with the jeep business
i mean uh you look at a product like the
wrangler
the wrangler for ever has been a
monopoly
you know the margins they have on the
wranglers are insane because there's no
com
there's been no competition now
the four ford has introduced the bronco
and there's some companies trying to go
but
when i when i talk to wrangler owners
they will not buy any other car
to them no other car exists
okay so it's that means you've got a
very serious motor on that business
right yes thank well thank you for
sharing that yeah that was
yeah yeah um i guess is my
as my uh final question that i'm curious
to ask you about
um before we wrap this up i know you
said in terms of one of the
greatest lessons you pulled was digging
into warren buffett's
shareholder letters and finding the
mistakes
are there any other areas that
people who do want to become great
investors should look into
and study and research besides just
warren buffett's
shareholder letters that you would
recommend well i think there's
there's many individuals that are worth
studying
uh i think that if there's a friend of
mine in the uk
nick's sleep and he
retired in 2014 but
his letters are on the internet nomad
investment partnership and so
they are wonderful to read so i think
there's there's
uh there's a number of great investors
and uh some have written books and there
are other resources of the given
talks and so on so
i think there's if if one is interested
in the area
uh there's plenty to uh to read and
think about
right well thank you so much uh that was
it was pleasure and honor to um ask you
these questions and talk to you and
um get your feedback uh on just an array
of things i know it was a
lot to cover but thank you so much
jeremy it was a pleasure thank you very
much
thank you if you want to see me talk
money with tony robbins check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there tony welcome
aboard man
thanks evan great to be with you